the third season of Star Trek strange
new worlds is actually at risk of being
canceled
what Madness is this but these are the
honest conversations that have happened
in the management Halls of Paramount and
CBS Studios and I've got a source that
was involved in those conversations
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
thank you
[Music]
so I'm going to say look this is not
them actually planning to do this this
is just them talking about it and
considering the possibility that they
might cancel Star Trek Strange New World
season 3 and replace it with a TV movie
there are lots and lots of reasons why
they're going to do this we're going to
discuss in a minute but I've got to
start off by saying I really like Star
Trek strange new worlds I really really
hope they don't follow through with this
because it's a show that I actually
really like even though there are
certain episodes I'm not Sakina I would
actually be genuinely gutted if these
conversations turned into more and this
strange new worlds did get canceled
now there's a lot to unpack in a lot to
get through
so I'm first of all I'm just going to
tell you a little bit about the source
that I've been speaking to now this is a
source that I've got information from in
the past through a third party but I've
never actually been able to speak to
them directly myself
this changed over the weekend and I was
able to have quite a long conversation
with them I have been able to confirm
that they are who they say they are
actually it was incredibly easy to do
that and that they actually are in the
position they say they are to know this
information I cannot say more than that
but I will say that if I was able to
give you the name you would be able to
check this for yourself I.E who they are
it's blah blah blah very very easily I
can't say more than that so let's go
back to Strange New World season three
now this was this close to actually
begin filming before the strikes
basically shut everything down Akiva
goldsmen actually at an MIT event even
said mistakingly that filming had
started it hadn't but never mind it was
that close though I mean they were
talking days until filming was supposed
to start when it was actually decided to
put it on pause thanks to the strikes so
if it was so close the development work
is done all the sets are built and
actually remembering season two ended on
a massive cliffhanger why are they
talking about potentially canceling the
show well there are a couple of reasons
for one strange new worlds and all of
the Star Trek projects are actually
incredibly expensive and Paramount is
skint it has 15 billion quids worth of
debt but I'm actually going to talk
about that in the next video because
that leads into another big problem
actually for secret hideout the company
that produces Star Trek at the moment
initially the numbers the viewing
figures basically for strange new worlds
weren't great they improved towards the
end of the season but for the first five
or six episodes actually producers and
Executives at Paramount were very
concerned they actually thought at one
point that the series was going to bomb
they were really really worried that it
wasn't even getting into the top four or
five on the Paramount like top 10 list
never mind getting onto the Nielsen list
which is the top 10 of overall streaming
services now it did pick up towards the
end
um but we're actually going to talk
about one of the reasons why it picked
up towards the end and again this of
course concerns apparently with some
producers at Paramount and CBS Studios
but they did get into the Nielsen top 10
and actually by the end of it the
numbers were bad
but what is the controversy that I am
talking about that basically got them on
the Nielsen list
well it was Subspace Rhapsody the
musical episode now that did cause a lot
of people to talk now it was not all
good A lot of people hated the idea of
the music just as many people though
absolutely adored the idea now I said as
soon as it came out on this channel in
fact that this was not going to be for
me and I watched it and I didn't like it
I actually feel a bit cheated by it not
because of the show because actually it
was all right I suppose but because Star
Trek real estate is so valuable and by
that I mean we only get 10 episodes of
this show losing one of them to a very
high concept
quite self-indulgent really Star Trek
episode where everyone is singing all
the time
I just felt we were robbed of a Star
Trek episode now if they'd have done the
musical as a special 11th episode or say
you know like a Christmas special I'd
have been brilliant great I wouldn't
have felt cheated by it
but they didn't they did it as the ninth
episode in the season the episode that
really should have been the big episode
building up towards the end of the
season
but they didn't now that caused a lot of
interest in the show and a lot of people
that don't normally watch Star Trek did
come to the show but it caused a lot of
controversy with Star Trek fans as well
and there are producers currently at CBS
and Paramount that are very concerned
that there's a very toxic environment
building up around Star Trek and that
toxic environment has basically been
there since the beginning with secret
hideout the first season of Discovery
was very heavily influenced by basically
kurtzman's work on the JJ Abrams Star
Trek movies that is why we got those
Klingons the way we did that's why we
got some of the storylines that we did
a lot of trekkies my age Trek is really
really didn't like it and there's still
an awful lot of toxicity around
franchise some producers at CBS and
Paramount and this isn't Everybody by
any stretch of the imagination but some
producers including the person I spoke
to feels that that toxicity is only
actually harming the franchise and that
perhaps strange new worlds is not
helping the situation
mainly because though they're also
worried that the longer strangely rules
goes on the more it's going to harm the
original series and by that I mean it's
starting to trample on the original
series shows and the Canon now a lot of
trekkies know the Star Trek Cannon
really well and they know that strange
new worlds is changing a lot of it some
people are very very angry about that
I'm disappointed it's like I'm telling
off my child I'm disappointed with you
I'm not angry disappointed
and I just think that actually they have
a point here when talking about these
conversations at Paramount and CBS that
actually the longer strange new worlds
goes on the more it's going to harm
potentially the legacy of Star Trek the
Original Series
and it's really starting to again affect
the franchise a lot of people love that
original series and a lot of original
trekkies like myself think that's really
the daddy that these characters you know
Kirk spark Leonard Nimoy William Shatner
Etc kind of being disrespected in some
ways by strange new worlds trampling on
their turf and even though I don't think
that's really a big problem because at
the end of the day strange new rules is
a different show and should be treated
differently
it is maybe harming the overall Star
Trek Legacy the longer it goes on so
there's a cost point of view there's a
legacy point of view remember that word
it's coming back to that in a second
point of view and the original series
Etc and just basically the confusion in
this franchise in the whole
and there is also a conversation about
whether a TV movie might make more
impact so I can tell you that that is
the conversation that's been had that
maybe they cancel season three and throw
in a TV movie instead this would be
something that would follow section 31
with Michelle yo now I don't hate that
idea
here a bit but at least we would get a
conclusion two strange new worlds and if
strange new worlds is doomed and is
going to get canceled that would at
least mitigate some of the pain
there are two big reasons though why
this conversation even started
one being Star Trek Legacy I told you I
was going to come back to that word
fans are desperate for Star Trek Legacy
they really have gone mad over it there
is a massive campaign it's launched a
thousand memes and fans really really
want it they want to see caption seven
of nine Jerry Ryan is an amazingly
popular actress within the Star Trek
fandom and we really would give our back
teeth for that show
the problem is power Mount can't afford
to put it in their current calendar they
can't afford to have this many very
expensive sci-fi shows running side by
side
now I spoke to you a couple of months
ago because I knew this conversation had
happened then that actually maybe
strange new worlds would end after
season three and that that would then
move into Legacy
apparently those conversations because
the financial situation has got worse
has actually been brought around again
but as I said with strange new worlds
may be ending now instead but apparently
there is one very high up person at CBS
who's been making the argument that Star
Trek is
confusing and that it really desperately
needs to be simplified he's basically
make the point that there are three
different timelines going on
four really if you consider the animated
stuff which is slightly out of step with
Picard not much but slightly add a step
of Picard
and it's bloody confusing now trekkies
can follow it we know where strange new
worlds fits before the original series
we know where
um Picard sat and then that would move
into Legacy following the TNG which I
would consider like the prime timeline
that's the timeline we should be in and
then we know where Discovery was a
prequel and then actually jumped
hundreds of years into the future so we
can follow that
but sort of casual viewers people that
may be flipping it out to Star Trek a
little bit have no bloody clue and
apparently there's been several
questionnaires done about this very
subject asking people do you understand
where all these different shows fit
within the bigger universe and people
don't so this executive again I can't
name but is very high up of CBS has made
the argument that it needs to be
simplified that we need to have one
maybe two timelines going on now that if
he wins that argument basically means
Star Trek Academy that is set just after
discovery we believe a way into the
future beyond the Picard season the
prime timeline would potentially be at
risk
or strange new worlds which is obviously
set before Picard if we're assuming that
Legacy will become the actual Focus for
Star Trek in the next couple of years
and we return to the prime timeline
if he's actually successful and we only
get one timeline which I actually think
would be just glorious I would solo it
they can't both be in existence
because we'd have three timelines still
so what is the solution
I think Paramount because they haven't
got the money might just make the
decision to focus on one timeline and
that would mean that they would focus on
the new series of legacy
strange new worlds would come to an end
and they would do the follow-up movie
and actually Star Trek Academy which
again has kind of divided fans won't
ever actually make our screens
now I'm not saying this is definite
because it isn't what I'm talking about
here is a conversation within the
boardroom that has happened in the last
month or so a serious conversation
though that has been going around for
quite a while
thereof producers of Paramount in CBS
that don't like the way Star Trek has
become muddled in the last few years and
actually would like to see a
simplification and there are people
there that are very concerned about the
budgets of these shows that would quite
like to see the same thing so these
strikes may have come at the worst
possible time for Star Trek in a way
it might give Executives time to think
about the plan moving forwards and it
might give them just enough time to
actually reconsider some of them
and maybe consider a reset now that
could be a good thing it could be a bad
thing depending on which side of this
argument you're for and at the end of
the day would then depend how good a
show Legacy was if that's the direction
they decide to go but what is my
personal opinion
I do actually agree that Star Trek is
muddled I think it's confusing at times
and I think there's an awful lot going
on I think it's become a bit of a mess I
actually do think a simplification would
be great and I do think maybe two
timelines only would be a good idea so
which show goes for me it would be
Academy
but I'm not in charge but what trekkies
think does matter so why don't you get
into the comments and tell me what you
think do you think that actually there
is a bit of a confusion in Star Trek at
the moment and a simplification would be
a good idea or do you think actually no
there's a plan in place now let's stick
to it people get into the comments and
tell me exactly what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports a channel you can even get a
free gift after three months can't say
fairer than that you get to see those
videos without the adverts too
also you can go to
sidetrack.co.uk which is our dedicated
website where we write up stories about
all of the videos that we do
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign